hey guys it's Justine and I am super
hyped to show you the first look with
the new Google pixel 8 and Google pixel
8 Pro phones thanks to Google for
sponsoring this video now I can't quite
turn these on just yet and show you all
of the details but please be patient and
look for that review very very soon if
you are interested in purchasing one of
these new devices you could actually
shop them right here from this video
which is pretty awesome now I do already
have them unboxed so just take a little
look at how beautiful these colors are
and I'm always such a huge fan of the
pixel camera bump design like I just
feel like this strip kind of ties
everything all in together and anytime I
see them they just look so sleek and I
love this new blue color this is the new
pixel 8 Pro so nice so let's dive in and
learn a little bit more about each one
of these new phones now the pixel 8 Pro
has a triple rear camera with a 5x
telephoto lens a 6.7 in display that
adjusts between 1 and 120 HZ and an
average battery life of 31 hours this is
probably one of the most surprising
things it has has a thermometer you can
use this to quickly get a temperature of
objects just by scanning them now the
price is starting at $9.99 and it comes
in Bay porcelain and obsidian colors now
as a content creator I am always so
excited to test out these cameras on all
of these new phones and with new
improved lowlight photos front-facing
cameras for selfies and zoom the new
video boost technology will let us shoot
an HDR plus with enhanced color grading
for more pro video night sight will
allow us to also shoot better photos and
videos at night which I love taking
night photos so I can't wait to test
that out they also have some new
features like the magic editor best take
and the audio Magic Eraser to improve
all of our content that we create the
thing I love so much about pixel phones
is they have all these hidden little
features because it is Google they have
the ability to really harness the entire
ecosystem that is Google and put that
into a device the thing that I'm really
excited to test out is this audio Magic
Eraser because I feel like in the past
we've been able to remove things from
photos and videos but now being able to
remove things from audio and calling it
the audio Magic Eraser is is kind of
cute like I'm into that so this is the
pixel 8 Pro in the bay color and man I'm
obsessed with this color like it
actually matches my sweatshirt quite
well it just looks so good it also has
kind of like a matte finish on the back
whereas the pixel 8 has more of a glossy
finish so now moving on to the pixel 8
this has upgraded rear cameras powerful
security and an all day battery life
with a new Google tensor G3 it has a 6.2
in display with an improved 120 HZ
refresh and with also up to 31 hours of
battery life now pricing for this starts
at $6.99 and comes in Hazel Rose and
obsidian the new upgraded camera has
advanced image processing for more
colors and details and I love that it
now has a macro focus and using best
take you can combine multiple photos of
people in a group and choose to edit a
person from another photo like in case
they have their eyes closed or much like
my other sister who never likes any
photos that we take and we have to take
a million of them this way we don't have
to take as many cuz she can just pick
her favorite shot out of the group photo
and we're like cool replace actually is
Magic now both phones have a really
Sleek design with dust and water
protection up to ip68 with the new
Google tensor G3 this is the pixel's
most powerful chip that allows you to
bring the latest in Google AI and
machine learning to these new phones now
like I said there is this new magic
audio eraser that lets you erase
distracting sounds from video and that
again is using Ai and the power of the
new Google tensor chip now like I said
if you are interested in getting these
devices you can shop it directly here
from this video which is pretty awesome
with YouTube shopping my sister and I
are also going to be doing a live stream
to celebrate the launch of these phones
on October 11th so stay tuned for all of
the information I'll be scheduling here
on my channel so you'll have all of the
details and you can sign up ahead of
time so that you can watch it when we're
actually live it's going to be so much
fun and I can't wait to test these out
if there's anything else that you'd like
to know about either device or you'd
like to see me test out in my review
please share them in the comments below
I can't wait to hear from you guys and I
look forward to shopping with you on our
live stream I'll see you guys then bye